[Music]
well this is it our last direct message
before Donald Trump is sworn in as the
45th President of the United States
according to half the media and
countless celebrities January 20th will
be the beginning of the Armageddon
according to trump supporters and lots
of anime avatars on Twitter January 20th
will be the single greatest day in world
history I however think that the truth
lies somewhere in between the blow va
ssin of Michael Moore and the memes of
Pepe the Frog in the space between these
two extremes is some incredibly fertile
ground for those of us who want to make
this country sane again think about it
when was the last time you felt that
there was so much going on that was
changing the world all around us all at
once maybe you're thinking back to eight
years ago when Barack Obama ran on hope
and change but actually think that
there's more opportunity right now than
there was then we can debate whether
Obama was a good president or not I'd
say pretty much yes on domestic policy
and basically no on the international
front but in terms of actual change did
much really change or did the system
just keep chugging along by the way I
don't have much of a problem with that
system chugging along for all its faults
our system is still a pretty great one
but if change was what you wanted eight
years ago I'm not really sure that's
what you got with Trump though there can
be no doubt that change is coming
everything about Trump from the way he
debated to his tweets to his cabinet
picks have been different than anything
before you may not like any of his
tactics or his choices but you can't
argue that change isn't happening right
now this very second and if you don't
like the change that you see it is your
duty as a citizen to have your voice
heard get out there protests are
volunteer be part of the process with
which you're so upset right now of
course by the same token if you're happy
Trump won and you think he's the answer
to political correctness and the rest of
society's ills then you're about to be
tested too it's one thing to be against
political correctness and for free
speech when you're in the opposition but
it takes real character to be against
political correctness and for free
speech when it's your guy that the words
are aimed at
I think that most of you who watch this
show aren't really on either one of
these teams and instead care more about
principles than party actually I really
believe it's not just you watching this
channel who believe this but it's pretty
much everyone out there who isn't on the
democratic or republican payroll many
Republicans made it clear they wouldn't
work with Obama which led to gridlock
which led to Trump now many Democrats
are making it clear that they won't work
with Trump which really just makes them
as bad as the Republicans they've been
complaining about for the past eight
years
this isn't how our system is supposed to
work by constantly being held hostage by
two parties who care more about stopping
the other one from succeeding than doing
anything positive themselves this is
clearly where we are however and this is
why change real change is needed now
more than ever the change shouldn't be
about whether you vote for a Democrat or
vote for a Republican though it should
be about how much power we give any of
these people to control our lives
violent protests which unfortunately I
think we're gonna have more and more of
will only bring more authoritarianism
and state power we need to change
attitudes and win the battle of ideas
not just the battle of the day that's
why I've spent the last year-and-a-half
talking about having honest
conversations and dealing with difficult
topics every time we forego real debate
and silence our opponents we spawn a new
set of people who will come in with easy
answers this is the space that the true
bigots and actual authoritarians will
flourish in it doesn't matter if they're
far leftists who want to silence critics
or far rightists who want to kick out
immigrants they don't want conversation
they want control it's also why I'm
completely convinced that a new center
is developing faster than even we
realized traditional labels are becoming
increasingly meaningless as people
realize that the battle is no longer
Democrat versus Republican nor is it us
verse then the battle lines are now
those who are truly for freedom versus
those who would stifle it in the name of
tolerance or in the name of security
thanks to the internet though and the
rising group of voices who are calling
out this nonsense
we're starting to win some of these
battles and if Trump has taught us
anything people like a winner
well all right Donald you won so now
it's time to do some real interviews and
respond to some real criticism I've got
a chair for you right there
so while maybe I've lost the left or the
left has lost me I now see that fertile
ground that I'm gonna start planting
some seeds these seeds will not only be
to grow new alliances with liberals and
conservatives but even Marxists and
progressives I have no desire to silence
them or any of the people I disagree
with I want to continue to talk about
the ideas which will help us avoid that
whole pesky Armageddon thing that I
mentioned earlier we can do this
together not by deep platforming and
through violence but by consistently
showing that the ideas of freedom and
liberty and the rights of the individual
are the best way to attain a society
that values true human equality joining
me this week is author radio host and
columnist Dennis Prager a few weeks
before the election I was at an event
for his YouTube channel Prager
University and I heard Dennis's keynote
speech
I heard Dennis speak through his
conservative lens about how the
wonderful experiment that is America and
his deep concern for the future of this
country
well I know we have our disagreements
about religion gay marriage abortion and
a bunch of other things I see Dennis as
someone I can build a bridge with
because he'll honestly tell me what he
believes and I'll do the same for every
liberal that he may convert to
conservatism I think I can convert just
as many conservatives to liberalism and
as I said before these labels are
becoming more and more meaningless by
the day it doesn't matter if we agree on
every little thing what matters is that
we'll defend the other person's right to
liberty and freedom as we enter this new
phase of change it'll be up to us as to
whether the change is positive or
negative
our system is stronger than one man but
one man can change the world let's trade
hope and change for the courage of our
convictions and let the chips fall where
they may
[Music]
you